so guys thank you for coming after
lunch if you check the schedule the
title is likly no it's not slly
different it's completely different but
the topic is is the same I just changed
the title because I was assuming that
what I'm doing is really very simple and
is really just that so we are applying
knowledge compilation techniques to the
specific inference in graphical models
required by causal inference and more
specifically our focus is on
counterfactual in to give you a bit more
context so this was the original title
of my talk and this is the title of a
paper we recently vot together I'm
Alexandro I'm from IIA which is a Swiss
AI lab I wrote together with my
colleagues a Marco zafalon and David
Uber who is a student in our group and
is a joint collaboration joint work with
the group of adish anden is the student
of and I think this sentence I stole
from Old Paper by the group of darish is
kind of telling what what we are trying
to to do so knowledge
compilation is basically trying to to
solve in a general in a stretched sense
to solve a complex problem typically
comple problems in higher complexity
class with respect to MP and what we are
doing is considering a very challenging
problem
which is the bounding of counterfactual
queries in structural causal models and
we are we want to do that by means of
knowledge compilation by means of
tractable tractable circuits basically
so this is what we we did as not
everybody here is from AI I'm spending a
bit of time just saying something about
General AI stuff actually prob most of
the people coming here at this moment is
from AI but let me still say something
give some some context here the dates
you can read are very very approximate
but this is just to to give a point
about where we are so and this is also
just to mention that what we are doing
is completely in the field of the pear
approach to causality what we do is
Computing inference in structural caal
models Al structural causal models in a
sense are the evolution of beion
networks so beion Network have been
proposed long time ago people start to
focus on inference on probabilistic
inference in these associational
correlational
models stable circuits have been from
from a certain perspective proposed
exactly to address inference in
graphical graphical models in the
meanwhile research on causality based on
graphical models go ahead and what we we
are trying to do is to go back so use
these tools originally derived for Bion
networks in the field of Cal models so
this somehow the setup of course there's
a lot of people working with
probabilistic circuits this community is
is part of them but there are new
relations between these approaches and
caal
Analysis okay this is not that important
but you know yesterday Casio was
emphasizing and I totally agree with the
be success of deep learning I will say
in the last 10 year but I'm very
impressed also by the success of deep
learning in the last year so if you
believe what if you think what is
happening with the large language model
and so on this is amazing no discussion
but a point of again darish and per and
other people is that okay we are looking
for intelligent system what deep
learning is doing is mostly elaborating
a system for sensing so we have very
good we computer vision we have very
good speech recognition what was not
obvious but we are realizing is that we
have also very good language models so
if human vision is a complicated
function deep learning is good in
approximating this function and this is
true for speech recognition and this
seems to be true also for natural
language processing for what we call
language maybe this is true for all the
human activities maybe there is room
still for reasoning techniques for
symbolic approaches that need to be used
to really achieve intelligent behavior
and this is especially true for causal
analysis and if you are familiar with
many comments many books many papers of
judia pel you probably read this kind of
sentences about the importance of the ca
meaning in the sense that we should be
ambitious we should capture correlation
but we can can do
more and this uh this picture is also
from the book of f is the so- called
ladder of causation I think is nice is
more than that there is also a formal
characterization provided especially
byas baring Bo is like the three
different levels and if you want machine
learning is here machine learning is
about some machine learning about
finding very good correlation and doing
very good prediction based on
correlation re enforcement learning is
one level up in the sense that is about
Computing the effect of an intervention
of an action so is the reasoning
provided that we did something but even
more challenging and the focus of my
talk is on counterfactual reasoning
where we kind of distinguish between the
real war what where we observed
something and an hypothetical
alternative word where we did a
different action so we have room for a
contradiction between the action the
state of the variable in the real world
and the state of the variable after an
intervention in an alternative world so
this is what counterfactuals are
about okay here I'm trying just to say
that this three different levels
correspond also to different levels of
complexity from a probabilistic
graphical model perspective so in
observational query we can say we have
observational data empirical data we
compute we learn Vision Network and we
just compute a single inference to
answer an observational query updating
or whatever say that we are interested
in intervention say that there is a
special class of Interventional queries
that can be somehow reduced to standard
queries in a basan network which are the
so-called identifiable queries do
calculus par do calculus is a graphical
approach is about that say that the
query can be reduced to a number of
observational queries so you can do this
kind of computation and basically you
can run multiple basan Network inference
or whatever and obtain the result of the
intervention counterfactuals generally
speaking having much more challenging in
the sense that in general
counterfactuals are only partially
identifiable is that you cannot exactly
compute the probability Associated to a
counter Factor you can only bound the
counter Factor and if here you have you
are required to compute a finite
sometimes very high number of of
inference in the graphical model here is
like an optimization problem over a
continuous domain and generally we can
prove that this is n p PP out just to
say that is a more complex task and we
are focused on this task on bounding the
counterfactual query on Computing the
the bounce of this of this
interval okay just let me say that in
this area do calculus is a possible
approach but because of do calculus you
have to compute multiple inference in
the visan network the group of Rea
dector recently is working this
direction but from an alternative
perspective and is trying to use em to
compute also the probability over the
variables that are not in the data set
and basically to compute by a single
query the answer if you if you want a
lot of people especi no not especially
but of course our group but also other
people is trying to to compute the
bounds of counterfactual queries we
initially did something in the field of
cral network I'm saying something about
that then we moved the to em
approaches uh some other people like
alas these are let's say the the leader
the the main leader is not there are
lots of authors in this paper but this
is the group of alas baren who is trying
to do this approach based on sampling
some other people people is doing
polinomial programming to solve this
optimization task we are trying and this
talk is about doing DM but together with
knowledge competition so this just to
have some framework I know some of you
is very into Cal model but let me say
some background let me use a very
trivial one univariate example useless
but just to define the language so we
have a variable we can observe
we call this endogenous variable and
let's say we have data we have an observ
a set of observation about this data so
we do some statistical learning and we
learn a distribution over the endogenous
variables but we assume that this
variable has been let's say determined
by a latent variable we call this
variable exogenous and there is a
structural equation determining the
state of the endogenous variable from
the exogenous
one
okay so basically every state of u
determines a corresponding state of X in
this example I have four state for U and
two state for x and this is the equation
whatever and uncertainty on the latent
variable propagates and becomes
uncertainty on the endogenous variable
so basically what we observe is this but
if we assume that X is produced by a
latent variable this probability should
coincide with this
probability if we have a distribution
over U we can compute the corresponding
distribution over X but in practice we
have the distribution over X and we have
to go back invert the relation and
computed the distribution over U because
it's what we eventually need to compute
the caal queries but this mapping is not
one to one generally speaking we cannot
invert this mapping and so if we go back
from X to U we will obtain a set of
so-called consistent with empirical
knowledge distribution over the latent
variable over the exogenous variable and
that's why queries like the
counterfactuals are only bounded also
called partial identifiable because we
have different values of P of U giving
different output to the query and so the
result of the query is only bound there
is no way that one of these
specification is more exact than another
one the bounds are not Els the bounds
are
intrinsic
please what is Delta F sorry what is the
Delta that is Chron Delta so so actually
this is total probability theorem so
this is the conditional probability as
we have an equation the probability is
one where X is equal to the the output
of the of the structural equation and
zero the
wise so it's one if they are equal and
zero
otherwise thaton
Del okay so and now this I think this is
an interesting point because just to say
that this is a conditional probability
in B networks we are required to
quantify this conditional probability
this is a Bas network if you want but is
a special basion Network because this
conditional probability table is the
generate the columns are made only of
zero and once and this is something we
are going to exploit during the
knowledge compilation proc
process okay you know F sorry yeah yeah
it can be discussed let let me give me
give me a second but it can be it can be
discussed but initially I'm assuming
it's a good point of course uh okay this
is just the general case which is the
real case because we never use model
based off single variables and okay
generally speaking we have a collection
of endogenous and a collection of
exogenous variable a collection of
equations typically we assume that the
latent variable are the root of the
graph this is soal semi markovianity
assumption but let me be quick on that
so you might see a strong relation with
Bean networks and actually from a
certain point of view a structural
causal model alel is just a ban Network
it's just a ban network with very
special conditional probability table
with deterministic conditional
probability tables implement ing the
structural
equations okay this assuming that
everything is specified and this is what
I call a fully specified structural
causal model but in practice we might a
critical point are the structural
equation but let's for the moment assume
that we have the structural equation the
second point is that these are the
marginal over the root nodes which are
exogenous which are latent and generally
speaking we don't have these
distribution
so the problem again is to invert the
mapping we have the endogenous
observation and we should go back but
when we go back we have a multivalued
specification of the P of U so this is
the setup so is more complicated but we
we generally real scenario we have to
cope with only partially specified
structural causal model okay I'm
assuming that we have the equation but
let's say that we don't have the
equation if we don't have equation we
can consider a conservative approach let
me use this example so we have a Boolean
variable and bull variable and these are
endogenous these are
observable and we have a latent
exogenous parent for each value of U the
relation between X and Y should be
deterministic so in a sense the role of
U is just to index the possible
deterministic relation relations between
X and Y say we have Tu variables we only
have four possible deterministic
relation y can be always zero why can be
always one why can be X and Y can be not
X so we have four mechanism and the role
of U we need the four states we don't
need more than four states of U to
enumerate all the four possible
mechanism this what uh we call the
canonical specification of the
structural equation of course if the
model has many par
the number the cardinality of youu you
need to enumerate all the possible
mechanism Rose exponentially so this can
be an
issue but let's say and let me also say
that if you have some domain knowledge
about the system you can and you
typically discard some of the possible
mechanism let's say that this is a
disease let's say this is coid and this
is a coid test and let's say that for
some reason it doesn't make sense that
test that always tells you that you have
coid maybe the test is broken and it
always says that you don't have coid but
this one makes no sense for some reason
or this will be the perfect test this
will be the anti- perfect test so the
test always telling you that if you are
sick you're not and you're if you're not
sick you're sick maybe it might makes no
sense so let's discard these two states
so we don't need four states we need two
and this is okay what we try to do to
let's say to address the problem of this
ification of the equation so let's say
for the moment that we have the
structural equations we have the
endogenous data we want to learn the
latent if the model is fully specified
we have the latent so if the model is
fully specified we have a ban Network so
let's use ban Network inference
exponential in the three we and faster
it can be faster in the presence of
context specific dependence Something
That You Don't See see from the graph of
the model something you can see in the
tables and you can also take advantage
of deterministic relations in in your
model and knowledge compilation is very
good because in some sense is
visualizing is explicitly producing
smaller circuits in the presence of this
kind of uh advantage of good let's say
situation from the perspective and
especially determinism is very appealing
from our perspective because our model
are deterministic the conditional poity
are deterministic in structural Cal
model and this is an interesting
empirical test if you take some random
structur causal model you run a
knowledge compilation you can see that
heav models with high three width are
tractable and the reason is the terminis
the reason is that the compiler is
taking advantage of the recover
structure of the presence of this Z1 to
make smaller circuits and then to have
let's say tractable results these are
results from Vision networks forced to
be deterministic or to have a context
specific Independence but the message is
that if you have determinist the
compiler can take advantage out of it
and there is an interesting notion of
causal Tre with so is the three we take
into account that you have a structural
causal model with a deterministic CPT
and this is generally speaking smaller
it can be equal but smaller than the
actual three wi of the model so this is
explicitly showing the advantages of the
terminis in CER models when you run a
knowledge compilation can you compute it
in advance the coal three can you
compute it no no this is operational but
you have to to do that yeah yeah yeah I
think this is still open I this darish
stuff and
so and let me also mention that we will
use for this stuff standard compilers
which can I mean general purpose
compilers this I see from the group of
UCLA maybe there is room to specialize
this compiler to this structure so maybe
we can take further advantages of this
structure is one of the open question
from my
perspective okay this was assume here
was assuming that the model is fully
specified if the model is not fully
specified so if we should go back to the
P of U from the X to the U uh okay in
some case we have these do calculus so
we can the quer is identifiable but
generally speaking we have to compute
the bound the task is
challenging and it can be proved that is
equivalent to this credal network to
this generalized basion Network and this
is another way to see why you need to
compute bounds and not the sharp values
for for for the query in a sense a
partially specified structural causal
model is just a collection of fully
specif spe ified of all the fully
specified structural caal model that are
compatible with the data with empirical
observation and the BS are computed with
respect to this collection of
models okay here I think I can not skip
but just be very quick on that is just
to showing the the mapping we derived
between these models and credal networks
which is not necessarily operational but
it's just to show you an explicit
formulation of this set of compatible
structural causal model so if you want
this is the compatibility constraints
this is a model with four endogenous
variable the U are the latent variables
these are the equations and this is just
the joint probability of the vision
Network the Delta are the conditional
probability tables these are the
probability of the root nodes we
marginalize the latent variable and the
result should be the empirical model
this is already the constraint this
constraint of compatibility but this
constraint is global it's involving all
the variable together and it's
nonlinear what we can do please are the
latent variables are they considered to
be independent yeah yeah because this
semi marity assumption so they are root
variables and so for the semantic of
directed graphs that they are depend so
the joint probability of the U is the
product of the dis prob can I have the
same variable being input to multiple
yes yes this is what we call a Marian
model but there are no model Mar where
the U is a part of multiple is a
confounder between two or more variables
of
course and in fact this ah let me show
you the mapping the mapping basically is
reducing these Global and nonlinear
constraints with respect to the P of U
to a collection of
local one separate constraint for each
latent variable and linear
constraints so we decompose the global
constraints into linear one and this
give you a proper credal Network
specification in the movian case which
is the case where we you have a single U
for each Parable this is Trivial in the
case of compounder it still doable is
what what we do the problem is what we
we have a parent with multiple latent
parents sorry a variable an endogenous
variable with multiple latent parents
this is more more tricky and that's why
basically okay we do inference we we can
use Cal Network inference algorith to
solve Cal inference but that's why this
is something we did like two years ago
and at some point we realized that we we
should do more H this is for a standard
Interventional query you do what P call
the surgery on the model and then reduce
the query to a standard query in the
graphical model for counterfactual you
have to duplicate the endogenous
variable because you have the actual
word and the alternative World some
people call this a twin
Network let me go faster and
basically after this cre Network watch
which is still important to understand
what is the problem the shape of the
problem we have the problem to of
practically compute these uh these
credal sets these sets of distribution
and then the bounds of the query and so
we consider an em approach why we
consider em approach because the latent
variable are missing by definition they
cannot be observed so they're missing at
random so we are in a setup for running
theem algorithm and this is basically
what I I will detail a bit this algorith
but this is basically what we can do the
point is that as there are multiple P of
U this is kind of trivial we just do the
expectation over the different by by
Computing the query for all the element
in the data set and then the maxim ation
we compute the new probability and we do
that in iterative way if you are
familiar with the m this is really a
trival example of
m the m go to a stationary point of the
likelihood you can prove this important
fact so the fact that if the output of
the m is the global maximum and you know
what the global maximum is because the
global maximum is the is basically the
likelihood of the empirical model if you
get the glob maximum you getting a point
of the cral set so you can use the
corresponding the pointed by the m to
compute the the Cal inference and by
doing that iteratively for multiple
initialization of the M you obtain an
inine approximation of this interval
valued query this is the
idea I'm not entering in detail we have
a credible intervals and in practice we
can compute very good inner
approximation with a low relatively low
number of uh initialization of different
initializations this is the algorith and
my focus is here this is the expectation
step and we need to compute inference
after the initialization of the
parameters we have to compute inference
in a fully specified structural causal
model this is a b Network inference if
you want but we have a comput lots of
these inference and we have also we also
want to compute the likelihood which is
the stopping condition so we stop when
the likelihood achieve a
maximum and uh this this is something we
want to make faster and this is where
let's say a knowledge compilation comes
into the play so to make faster this em
approach first of all we can notice that
there is a lot of room for
parallelization we're running multiple
initialization so all the initialization
can be executed in parallel we have to
compute the inference over the posterior
inference for each latent variable over
the the records in the data set so this
can be done in parallel and there there
is a fter level of parallelization at
the level of the soal C component of the
model but what is even more important
for us we want to do knowledge
compilation to have a faster inference
on these basion networks if you want but
we have a lot of different model because
every time we have a different
initialization the m is an ative
approach every time we have a different
initialization a different iteration
with different parameters so all these B
networks are different so it seems that
we need to recompile the model every
time which is demanding from a
computational point of view but and this
is the point basically of this of this
work we have to run a lot of inference
in different models but all these models
share the same graph they have the same
variables and they have the same
equations so the compilation the
compilation process can be done somehow
at a symbolic level maybe parameterized
is a better word but initially we use
the symbolic a let me explain this by
this example okay this is a be Network
it's not a structural causal model this
is the beion network let's say that the
the Distribution on this root node is
not specified is a
symbolic this is the compiled model this
number 02 eight are ER but even the
parameters P of A and P of B are ER and
er of course we are not adapting this
software to process this kind of
symbolic
computation compilation explicitly we
just specify for all the parameters that
we want to regard as a parameter some
random number unique random numbers and
then we have a kind of Ash so we know
that this number correspond to this
position that this this number
correspond to this position if we have
to change let's say if you have to
produce the the circuit for a different
specification of this model we just
change the value of this parameter
directly in the circuit so we don't have
to reexecute the compilation process is
a very simple idea but in practice we
save lot of time because we do a single
compilation instead of a lot of
compilations so this is our point we did
some preliminary experiment of course
you see that this is the compared to the
the standard model if you do
parallelization you you reduce the time
by a factor of two if you do this
symbolic compilation you reduce the
execution time by a factor of five and
overall we we have an order of magnitude
but these are very preliminary
experiments the parallelization you can
do much more with parallelization and we
intend to improve a lot this compilation
part so this is the general idea I'm
about to
finish okay let's say in this way anyway
I think that we we are writing an
extended version of this paper we want
to claim that we are say the state of
the art for the computation of these of
these bounds with with regard to
existing uh methods what about the
future work we need okay we are using
general purpose compilation algorithm
basically this a
of darish maybe there is something a do
for the canonical the canonical is all
the possible mechanism if you remember
between a set of variables maybe you
first order guys you have some first
order circuit that can Implement in a
more compact way this kind of
relation uh there are okay a connected
component basically we we do a single
compilation on the wall model but we
have a kind of the composition of the
model so ideally we would like to do the
compilation separately for each
component and then merge the result this
probably can be done this is not
complicated this for me is complicated
this also might be complicated because
we have this twin network with a a
different replica
of of the endogenous variable for each
word for each word maybe you can do some
lifted inference also what we are doing
and on purpose is a query agnostic
approach so we do what the compilation
and then depending on the query we run
maybe we can do something specific for
the query so there is a lot we can do
also the we propagate single values
maybe we can propagate all the
initialization together in this clear
sense but this is more complicated and
of course we have to do a better
implementation of the paralyzation we
plan to use a Julia which is better
choice for that that's it maybe having
time thank you guys for your
[Applause]
time do we have
questions I think yes uh very nice talk
thank you uh I have a general question
and more specific one the general
question is many of the uh uh methods
that you are proposing in here are
applicable outside causality namely we
always had baset Network and learning
based network with em and how to do it
efficiently so many of the ideas
especially compilation that you are
proposing
are applicable in the general uh case um
so that's just a
statement I say that yeah were we just
specialized this idea to this so it's
applicable in general but uh my question
is about your assumption you assume that
the functions are known in this setup
normally the assumption is that they the
the functions are not known uh how do
you do can you use the idea of
compilation also that you compiled once
uh also when the functions are not
known I I don't know I don't know I I
can tell you what we are trying to do we
are trying to do to assume that the
function are not given the the
cardinality of the latent variable are
given and we are trying to learn by em
like a approaches the best equations
once we have the equation we will go for
the compilation not sure you if you
suggest to do the two steps together at
this stage we are uh we are splitting
the the task so first we assume that we
have the cardinality and we learn by
standard techniques with am that the
best reduced equation and then we go for
comp can I follow up okay uh so a one
thing that you uh arguing is that a
compilation is very good in this case
because we have functions so this is
just an observation you can map any
Basin Network to one where you have
these uh functions that you restrict
yourself to a fun to functions with uh
this hidden varibles so while I agree
with you that if the if it's h you have
functions I mean compilation is likely
to be good but the con the idea that any
basic Network can be Express this so
yeah so there is a this is a
counterargument that the compilation
will have the the the usual limitations
sometimes it will be good sometimes it
regular or other methods for inference
can be equally good so I'm just this is
just an observation I see I see but
maybe you can say that of course to to
achieve that so to map the ban Network
to a structural Cal model you need
additional variables you need more let's
say
yeah uh you yeah the hidden you you will
need to add hidden variables and the the
number I mean to to model with the
hidden variables the the probabilities
that you that you have okay thank you
thank
you any other
questions okay so let's thank the
speaker once
more